it's like I wear this I get judged you
know if I get invited to a fancy
black-tie event as me then I wear my
hoodie and slacks and my shoes and I
presented a ward where everybody else is
in tuxedos and some people think that's
inauthentic or unprofessional I'm not
trying to upset I'm not trying to make a
point just this is me this is how I roll
I I was just with Alex right now and he
helped me come to this realization that
I wasn't being real so you can't realize
you weren't being yourself yeah and then
authenticity okay every post I would
make fake okay did it feel fake it
wasn't as real as I knew could be okay
did you ever have that issue I feel like
I'm always there you know I feel like I
feel like I can always be more I feel
like I know if I catch you then I can
fix it but I try to be myself always I
try I try to be and it's one of the
comments that I get the most frequent is
like oh you're actually the guy that you
are in the videos I tried I try to be
that a quote that I reminded of his
jay-z and Warren Buffett we're doing an
interview and jay-z was asked you know
you're in these big boardrooms and
billionaires and they all had university
education and you know don't you feel
intimidated being with these people
and like not like they went to these
schools I went to the School of Life I'm
just I just me everywhere I go and I
really like that I think it's hard to be
you everywhere you go
I think if you're in an unfamiliar
situation you come to a new city you
know you go to a new event you can find
yourself quickly but I think it's often
hard to to be yourself and that's that's
what I don't think I always do the best
job of like here it's easier my
environment it's easier being somewhere
else somewhere new trying something
different I don't know that I'm always
like who I would like to be because of
even an insecurity that I don't even
know what it is it just feels off
and so so I like that like it's
frustrating I don't know how to fix it
but like I'll do it again and then try
to get better so I always see both it's
like I think I'm pretty good in day to
day but then there's situations where
something is a little missing and so I
want to continue to fix it improve it I
think whenever you find yourself
catching it then then just try to make
it better like if you find yourself not
being yourself in a situation like you
found that you weren't yourself here
fully one if it's like don't beat
yourself down I feel I have a lot of
Michael just have empathy for myself
like it's okay like be gentle on
yourself if you're in the if you're in
the hole and you feel like crap then be
gentle in yourself just to get yourself
back up to baseline and then and then
just do the thing like it's never too
late so it's day three great like I've
got I've got two hours left I'm gonna
make a count like I'm gonna I'm gonna do
something that makes because then you
get a win like try to end on the win so
you can be gentle with yourself and try
to end on a win so whatever like being
authentic looks like for you whether
it's a post whether it's giving brahim a
huge hug you know like he's a hugger you
know like whatever the thing is then
then then embrace that and it still may
not be what you fully want it to be but
it's it's a step like this the most
important thing is the first step
because it builds momentum what I hate
is when people quit because they get to
supporting themselves it's like you
weren't yourself you weren't listening
you know I said something about doing
more on so you were frustrated you
weren't doing you wanted to go and write
and then you wrote and even doing that
like if writing was the therapy like
leaving here even if you left or really
like you walked out halfway through like
I'm cool with that if you go and you
have to go write and writing this thing
that like brings you back the center and
say you know what I wasn't fully happy
with how I was yesterday not even for
anybody else like for you I was happy
with how I behaved yesterday I know I'm
better than that then to not leave like
the worst thing I think you could do is
leave Toronto feeling like your
disappointment
and you've never become the thing that
you are back home just knowing that you
you've made a little bit of progress
like you you were afraid to talk to
Danny because he's a scary-looking dude
but you haven't you said hi right and
that that was that was courageous right
or but like just trying to stop thinking
it and just you feel something then you
do it just like you just did now you ask
the question is a response yeah that was
it you thought about it you did it and
then and then congratulate yourself like
that's awesome like like high-five right
like I was myself great even if for you
even if for just for like the three and
a half seconds it took you to ask that
question you or yourself yeah and that's
great and you did it yeah it's like well
how do i do just did yeah it just
happened yeah and if writing this is the
is the therapy then if you're ever in
that situation again like excuse
yourself go to the bathroom and right
right like maybe all you need to do is
write an Instagram post or maybe you
need to sit there for two hours and
write pages until like you come back to
Center like that centers you great
you're centered you go back
and and take like build yourself a steam
around the fact that you went back and
you try to be yourself again like what
do you what are you so afraid of it's
usually like somebody's judgment right
and in you know you meant a lot not like
that I brought my dogs here no it's like
well you did but but but maybe you don't
maybe but like in the first session my
Tristana dog she peed on the floor she's
a month old and pees on the floor and
like ok it's a professional environment
you know we're learning here you
supposed to be inspired by me and Here I
am with my dog and she's peeing
everywhere
so either let that ruin the day or we
make it like the best part of the day
Yeah right like Rahim I turn around
inside peeing on the floor I mean I'll
talk to him after I come on man yeah but
in the moment it's like it's the best
yeah right but that's actually like my
dogs come with me everywhere right if
I'm here my dogs are here right so
that's it that's what it is like I wear
this I get judged you know if I get
invited to a fancy black-tie event as me
then I wear my hoodie and slacks and my
shoes and I present an award where
everybody else's and tuxedos and as some
people think that's inauthentic or
unprofessional I'm not trying to upset
I'm not trying to make a point it's just
this is me this is how I roll and
there's just being comfortable in that
but not everybody approves it and then
finding the thing so for me I just come
back to believe but for you if they're
coming back to writing like you should
always have a little little sticky note
ok yeah always do yeah so then like shut
out the world like go to the bathroom
there's always a bathroom anywhere you
are you know and put headphones on and
just write a couple pages and that soon
as you like it's awesome you found the
thing that can help you get centered
because a lot of people don't know what
that
everything that you're saying is yes it
I get it I understand it and that's why
I look up to you that's all you're my
role model and even stuff like that like
what I'm still getting used to hearing
that stuff right like I'm getting used
to saying I've never called anyone my
role model before ever there you go like
we're on the discomfort train together
right yeah but but it's important
especially I know if it's a Kenyan thing
but it's like humbleness and my parents
always cheer me to be humble but bye-bye
me say no I'm not like don't that's then
I cheat you of the gift that you're
trying to give me a gift it's a
compliment right so like I need to say
yeah thank you I appreciate that even if
I feel like okay I could do way better
and I'm working on it and trying to
prove but it's still it's still a gift
right so being able to receive and give
gifts to but that's me like just be you
everywhere that's it and you is awesome
and if writing is the thing like I'm
super pumped you found the thing that
sends you back because I don't think
brahim knows what centers him back yeah
I don't think he knows I don't think
what people know like it's awesome those
people don't know if they're stressed
out they don't know how to get back wow
wow oh my gosh your help it was a good
there it is again you real like you're a
real human being on this planet but
that's it it's always it's just that's
great give you one one suit once ball
what word ever if you had to think of
one word that's most important to you or
that sums you Apple
that would be collect a little beacon
this interview was done as a part of my
Toronto workshop if you want more
details on the next one to sign up check
out the link right there next to me
continue to believe and I'll see you
there